hey everyone i'm tamor and i recently
got to see eldon ring in action yep you
heard me right i got to see 15 minutes
of the game as well as get a
presentation from from software's
yasuhiro kital and i've thrown together
this quick collection of seven brand new
things that i learned about the game for
more on elder ring make sure to like
this video and subscribe to gamespot
[Music]
yep you read that right from software
games are known for their intricately
connected worlds where narrative is
delivered in fragmented pieces leaving
the player to make connections filling
gaps and draw conclusions so when rumors
that elden ring would be an open world
title started spill out people naturally
had questions but according to from
software's yasira kital however the team
didn't set out to even make an open
world title in fact from software isn't
even sure it has the correct definition
of what encompasses an open world
experience and so it isn't quick to call
elden ring one to be clear it is
unmistakably an open world game but one
that's cut from the same cloth as breath
of the wild rather than any of the
recent assassin's creed titles the
distinguishing factor between them for
me is how deliberate the construction of
the world feels and what the
moment-to-moment experience of
adventuring is like the lands between
where elder ring takes place is an
interconnected world that while vast
didn't look like it was big just for the
sake of being big visually it's
incredibly dense whether standing atop
craggy cliffs peering out over a land
blanketed in an ominous fog or trudging
through flooded cities from software
wants you to always be drawn towards
something of interest on the horizon and
hopes that along the way you may
accidentally stumble into something
unexpected like breath of the wild the
developer is counting on curiosity to be
your guide instead of dozens of icons on
a map similarly the things that you
stumble upon or have thrust in front of
you feel more emergent than in most open
world games in the hands of demo i saw
one such moment was a dragon suddenly
swooping down and engaging the player in
any other souls born game the telltale
signs of a scripted boss fight would
appear the terrifying but epic
orchestral score accompanied by a life
bar and a fog gate that signifies you
are definitely trapped but these
elements did not appear it was just an
incredibly pissed off dragon looking to
pick off a wandering warrior scattered
throughout the overworld are dungeons
that can be stumbled upon while
exploring these in classic from software
fashion are sometimes deadly detours
that invite the player to overcome traps
enemies hiding in dark corners and the
occasional boss in order to find
treasures interestingly the one eyesore
felt reminiscent of a bloodborne chalice
dungeon depending on your opinion of the
divisive chalice dungeons that may not
sound particularly enticing but i didn't
see enough of these dungeons to say
whether each of them is bespoke in its
design or procedurally generated like
many of the blood-borne chalice dungeons
however everything you know and love
from the soulsborne dungeon is otherwise
present there's intimidatingly large
blades swinging around environments
ready to cleave you into at the
slightest misstep there's monsters that
pounce on you as soon as you emerge from
a doorway and there's even a wooden
chest with a chain curved upwards
also scattered around the world are what
from software calls legacy dungeons the
name is intended to signify that these
areas present something akin to the
traditional souls-born gameplay
experience in a contained environment
the legacy dungeon we ventured into was
stormvale castle which in classic
soulsborne fashion is an expansive
medieval structure that dares the player
to breach its gates however a weathered
beastly looking figure wearing an ornate
book as a necklace who can be found
skulking in a dark corner nearby advises
you to do otherwise stormville's gates
are closed but he can request they be
open for you a foul tarnished in search
of the elden ring here's where things
change in a more obvious fashion the
player is presented with a choice they
can either request that the strange
figure give the signal to open the gate
or heed the warning and take a back
route that is much safer bold
adventurers will want to go through the
front gate but given the immediate
barrage of arrows that followed the
moment the tarnish crossed the threshold
i suspect they will realize that the
back route is the smarter option picking
one doesn't lock you out of the other
path however instead this choice is
presented as a kind of on-the-fly
difficulty decision difficult challenges
are the cornerstone of from software's
games but according to kital from
software's intention is never to create
a difficult game just for the sake of it
instead the team wants players to enjoy
the experience clear the hurdles and see
the game through it creates games with a
sense of value derived from overcoming
hardships and elden ring implements new
ways to do this one of these is by
taking mechanics from its last game
sekuro like zekiro's protagonist wolf
the tarnished is agile capable of
leaping into the air at a moment's noise
in gameplay terms this means that
platforming is now more integral to the
gameplay experience and as such
stormville castle is designed with
verticality in mind the tarnish is shown
jumping from rooftop to rooftop slinking
through an open window and down into the
castle out in the fields of the lands
between the tarnish can engage in
stealth avoiding combat entirely or
adopting an assassination oriented
playstyle in outright battle meanwhile a
leaping heavy attack will break through
an enemy starts leaving them vulnerable
in addition to creating exciting new
gameplay opportunities within the
soulsborne framework this new injection
of agility means people who may not be
as confident in standing their ground
and fighting towering beasts imposing
knights or deadly magicians have a way
to take some semblance of control in
battle they can dictate their pace a
little more another way they can turn
the tides in their favor is by summoning
what are essentially minions that will
fight for you these function similarly
to co-op partners but with decidedly
less staying power the summons i saw
didn't seem like they could stand up to
a boss but against a mob of enemies they
were effective at taking the pressure
off and even thinning out the crowd
kital said that elden ring aims to make
the most of its sprawling world so there
will be plenty of interesting places and
plenty of interesting people to discover
too from software describes the story of
elden ring as a multi-protagonist drama
while facing old heroes and demigods in
search of the elden ring the tarnish
will encounter a variety of characters
and the game is more focused on them
than any of from software's previous
titles characters have always been
crucial to the narrative of the
soulsborne titles you only have to look
at the fandom surrounding solaire sigma
mikolaish or genichiro and many of the
others to know how important they are to
from software's games and the people
that play them elder ring aims to double
down on characters to address the fact
that for many from software's games have
stories that are difficult to pass by
focusing on characters and the drama
surrounding them the narrative is
painted in a much clearer way
establishing a strong baseline that
anyone can enjoy that's not to say it
will be as straightforward as held as
something like sakura george r r
martin's involvement all but guarantees
that the song of ice and fire also laid
the foundation for elden rings mythos
creating characters rivalries political
entry corrupted lineages and more and
from software has built on this
foundation with its own brand of
storytelling according to qatar not all
of martin's work is represented in the
final game in some cases characters he
created aren't in the game but their
place within the history of the world is
represented this is the kind of thing
that will no doubt serve as fodder for
the obsessive soulsborne community to
dig into
that's a few things that we learned
about eldon ring for my full preview
head over to gamespot.com and for more
elden ring make sure to like this video
and subscribe to gamespot you can find
me on twitter at tomorrow h
you